media may be new to some of you but this
dish has been around for decades the
juicy slow cooked meat stew is often
served for special occasions and you'll
soon see why it's truly a mountain your
mouth experience that honestly deserves
its own holiday today we celebrate its
evolution by not only showing you how to
make delicious biryan but also how to
serve it taco style
[Music]
birya originated in the mexican state of
jalisco but it's believed to have grown
in popularity after don guadalupe
serapeberia stand in tijuana in the
1950s beta is traditionally made with
goat meat but reportedly zarate
eventually began to prepare it with beef
we tested a variety of meats goat beef
lamb and pork while we loved the classic
goat we decided to use beef for our
recipe it's more widely available but
still packed with flavor now that we've
picked our protein let's talk cuts we
want fatty meaty cuts in this recipe
we're using a mix of boneless beef chalk
roll and bone-in beef short ribs bones
are packed with collagen and flavor
adding richness to our consumer that
will have your lips sticking together in
a good way guentzeman is a savory brothy
sauce it's what we'll be dipping our
tacos in later
before we get to cooking we want to
season our meat with salt don't skimp on
the salt here people we want to coat our
meat completely then we'll chill our
seasoned meat in the fridge for at least
four hours seasoning our meat before we
sear it is going to give us that crispy
brown crust and lock in more flavor
alright let's move on to our chilis
everyone uses their own combo of dried
chilies today we're using morita
quajillo and ancho chiles morita chiles
for their spice and smokiness guajillo
chiles for their spice and sweetness and
ancio chiles for their dark richness
we'll cover our chiles with warm water
and let them soften for about 5 minutes
then we'll remove the seeds and stems
like this or under running water and set
the peppers aside but the spice doesn't
stop there incorporating more spices and
seasonings is gonna give us a
well-balanced birya that's layered with
flavor like chiles everyone has their
go-to seasoning for birya cinnamon
coriander seed bay leaves cloves
allspice dried avocado leaves black
peppercorns cumin and mexican oregano
there are two types of oregano italian
and mexican while they share the same
name they have different tastes and
aromas italian or mediterranean oregano
has minty undertones while mexican
oregano has more citrusy earthy
undertones for our recipe we're using
cinnamon coriander seed black
peppercorns allspice and cloves we'll
add them to a medium skillet and toast
them over medium heat then we'll
transfer them to a spice grinder along
with our dried bay leaves and mexican
oregano toasting and grinding our spices
will give our spice mix a fresher more
vibrant flavor you want to grind them
into a fine powder like this
now it's time to cook our meat
traditionally the meat is cooked
underground
we found the best way to replicate that
method was using a dutch oven with the
tight fitted lid we'll remove our meat
from the refrigerator and pat it dry
this will absorb any excess moisture
that could keep our meat from getting an
even crust
next we'll add a quarter cup of canola
oil to our pot over medium-high heat
once the oil is shimmery add the meat
and sear it on all sides we want to
create this really great crust all over
also known as the mayard reaction this
process is going to lock in yet another
layer of flavor to our braising liquid
once the meat is golden brown remove it
from the pot and set it aside we're
gonna go ahead and add our yellow onions
and quartered roma tomatoes sprinkle
them with a tablespoon of salt and let
everything cook until the onions and
tomatoes begin to sweat about five to
seven minutes then we'll add our garlic
and cook until fragrant as if our
kitchen couldn't smell any better we're
gonna add the spices we prepared earlier
cook until they're aromatic about 2
minutes
next we'll add a little apple cider
vinegar and 8 cups of water
why water and not beef or chicken broth
we're actually building our own broth
right in this pot so adding more beef or
chicken broth isn't necessary
we'll return our seared meat to the pot
toss in those chilies and bring
everything to a boil
then we'll reduce our stew to a simmer
and cover it with a lid
okay it's been about 30 minutes let's
give this a look
see how our mixture has reduced and the
chilies have completely softened that's
our cue that it's time to remove our
chilies and blend them we'll place them
in a high-powered blender along with two
cups of our broth
and blend
smooth and silky
[Music]
we'll add the chili mixture back into
our pot and give it a stir
now we'll start topping our stew with
banana leaves
[Music]
the banana leaves are going to add yet
another layer of flavor while also
preventing our meat from drying out
quick tip if you can't find banana
leaves use aluminum foil
and now for the hard part waiting we're
going to cover our pot and transfer it
to the oven to cook for 90 minutes
it might be the longest 90 minutes of
your life but hang in there see that
wasn't so bad we'll take off the lid and
remove the banana leaves
then remove the cooked meat from the pot
place it in a large mixing bowl and
start shredding the meat should easily
pull away from the short rib bones like
this
now it wouldn't be tacos without
tortillas and hey if you want to go the
extra mile and make your own more power
to ya but store-bought tortillas are
just as good for this and when it comes
to birya tacos our tortillas of choice
are corn here is when the magic happens
remember that warm flavorful liquid left
in our pot after we remove the meat
that's our consummate see that thin
layer of fat sitting at the top
we're gonna dip the tortillas in that
and lay them flat on our lightly oiled
skillet pan frying our tortillas in the
fat is what's going to give our tacos
that perfectly crisp crust we're
crisping our turkey on both sides so our
tacos don't fall apart there's some
debate about what we're about to do next
we're going to top our tortilla with
cheese we're using shredded oaxaca
cheese here because it's the best for
melting but mozzarella cheese is also a
good option
then we'll add our shredded beef and
fold the tortilla in half and we'll cook
it until the cheese begins to melt okay
time to flip
look at that golden brown color and
crispy crust this is what we want
we'll continue cooking to achieve the
same on the other side they say you eat
with your eyes and they're not wrong
wow
we came we cooked and now we're more
than ready to consummate these birya
tacos
all jokes aside we like to serve our
berria tacos with some cilantro pickled
red onions and lime and don't forget to
consume because dunking your taco in it
makes for one delicious bite these media
tacos are seriously worth every minute
and mess so do us a favor and make this
recipe and dip it like it's hot
[Music]
you